Over the past centuries, technologies have
regularly come along that completely change
how we connect to each other: the printing
press, the telegraph, the telephone; the newspaper,
the radio, the TV.
All are technologies that begin social
revolutions.
We’re living through one such revolution
now. It started in 1962 with a humble, almost
boring idea: connecting computers together.
Today, almost three billion people are connected.
What kind of revolution are we going through?
- Firstly, it’s fast. It took 25 years after
the Guttenberg Press arrived for the first
English book to be printed.
In its first twenty-five years, the telephone
reached just 10% of America.
In 1995, less than 1% of the world’s population
was connected. The first billion was reached
in 2005. The second billion in 2010. The third
billion at the end of 2014.
The benefits of the Internet are obvious
and all around us. In a European-wide poll,
people put the Internet at the top of their
list of daily essentials – ahead of the
bath,the car and the television.
But the risks and dangers are less obvious
and more subterranean.
There are at least four.
ONE - WE’RE ADDICTED
In the UK, two in five of us recognise we’re
spending too long on the internet but admit
we can’t stop.
Three in five of us check the internet the
first thing in the morning, and the last thing
at night - and put this habit ahead of interpersonal
communication.
Two in five women say that one of the greatest
challenges of relationships has become how
to prove more interesting than the partner’s
smartphone.
Nine out of ten people would rather be surfing
the web rather than reading a book.
Internet pornography has proved particularly
compelling: 60% of US adult males admit to
using it at least once a month. 9% of males
classify themselves as spending between 10
and 20 hours a week on porn.
We are not neurologically designed to withstand
the temptations on offer online - and this
suits a great many internet companies just
fine.
TWO - WE KNOW TOO MUCH AND UNDERSTAND TOO
LITTLE
The amount of information at our fingertips
is unimaginably large;
every single minute of the day:
Facebook users share 2.5 million pieces
of content.
Twitter users Tweet 300,000 times. YouTube users upload 72 hours of video
200million emails are sent. Apple users download 50,000 apps
Between the dawn of civilization and 2003,
5 exabytes of data was created. That much
information is now created every 2 days.
There is so much data that we keep having
to come up with new words to describe it.
The latest term is the yottabyte.
This much data is overwhelming and asphyxiating.
To manoeuvre, we have to rely on search engines.
Google makes 2.5 billion searches per day.
But we forget that these search engines are
mechanical and highly coloured in their interpretations.
For a start, they constantly direct our attention
to their products, sponsors, and affiliates.
Imagine the Dewey Decimal system owned by
Coca Cola.
A lot of the information is nonsense: during
the riots in London in 2011, the three most
shared stories on Twitter were that the London
Eye was on Fire, the Army was on the streets,
and that a tiger had escaped from London zoo.
Because the internet is often a source of
reliable information, we exaggerate its accuracy,
its importance and its wisdom.
The 12th most popular question typed into
Google is:
WHAT SHALL I DO WITH MY LIFE?
It doesn’t know, but at the same time, it
constantly gets in the way of the conversations
you might have with the one person who does:
namely, you.
THREE - PRIVACY IS UNDER THREAT
Thousands of ‘cookies’ track where
we go. Our mobile phones log data about our
movements every five seconds, even when they
are ostensibly off.
The head of the French police force proposed
it’s now almost impossible to commit a murder
and remain undetected.
We’re constantly leaving so-called digital
breadcrumbs on our online travels. Every year,
in the UK, we leave up to £5,000 worth of
data online which is sold to marketing companies
and harvested, filtered and cross-referenced
to provide detailed insight into our lives.
Facebook will know you’re gay before your
mother does.
70% of us admit to fearing how much we
have already shared. one in seven teenagers
in the US has sent a compromising image over
the internet and had a sexual chat with a
real-life stranger.
A majority of European internet users are
under the impression that a security service
has snooped into their conversations and activities.
FOUR - ONLINE CRIME IS OUT OF CONTROL
Over the last twenty years, crime has abated
in many countries. Since it peaked in the
UK in 1995, it has fallen by 60%.
But Internet crime is exploding.
In 1990 the NSPCC estimated there were 7,000
known images of child pornography at large.
In 2014, American law enforcement found 42
million images on just one server.
The UK Government estimates 50,000 people
in the UK are actively involved in downloading
and sharing images of child abuse.
Online abuse and hate-speech are endemic:On Twitter, 10,000 uses of racist slur
terms occur a day.
And 2000 Tweets are sent containing the
word ‘rape’.
69% of young people in the UK have experienced
cyber-bullying
The police are overwhelmed. The Head of
the UK’s National Crime Agency recently
said they would only ever be able to focus
on less than 1% of child porn users.
CONCLUSION
One view is that new technologies have always
brought anxieties with them, and that they
always turn out to be groundless.
Socrates in Plato’s Phaedrus warned that
books would promote forgetfulness. People
would become the “hearers of many things
and will have learned nothing”.
But that’s too rosy and too relaxed about
what we’re facing. Technologies can and
do bring serious lasting problems. As the
residents of Hiroshima realised.
The internet presents unrivalled challenges
to our abilities to:
- interact deeply with our partners
- keep our critical faculties alive
- stop thinking that the answers always lie
‘out there’.
- remain emotionally connected to real-life
people.
- and make the discoveries that come when
we are bored and letting our minds lie fallow.
We need to start to take active measures to
educate our children in the dangers of this
tool
reconnect with the natural world
talk to one another face to face
stop downloading images of naked people
get bored
and take regular digital sabbaths.
We need to learn to control ourselves not
because the internet is so bad, but precisely
because it’s so very very nice - in ways
that turn out to be deeply detrimental to
our ability to flourish and function..
We can accept that it is not a good thing
to let a fifteen year old boy have unmonitored
access to the internet in his bedroom. Not
because we think he is wicked. But because
we are generous. We understand that asking
for self-control in those circumstances is
too demanding. A similar argument applies
if you happen to be twenty six - or forty
six.
The internet has unparalleled power to get
in the way of almost every other rather important
and precious thing around - starting with
the rest of your life.